[Applause]
you're watching swipe is what's coming
up for you on this week's show Kitt's
at the UK's leading national security
event I meet the artists asking could
tech kill creativity and Simon brings us
a multiplayer showdown to keep you
thinking
[Music]
welcome to swipe from the Tate Modern in
London this week we're a little bit
later we'll be finding out what happens
when art gets tacky before then though
let's get a quick look at some of this
week's tech news headlines
blackberry is suing Facebook and it's
what's happened Instagram apps the
company argues they copied technology
and features from blackberry messenger
Facebook has said it intends to fight
the lawsuit Alexa play the last sound
Alexa has been surprising some of its
users by suddenly laughing unprompted
following the creepy reports Amazon's
told us that in rare circumstances Alexa
can mistakenly hear the phrase Alexa
laughed the company says it's disabling
that now and changing the voice
assistance response Alexa replay ubers
moving into hairstyling it's partnered
with a beauty tech platform to launch an
app that allows users to book a blow-dry
or styling in a moment's notice from a
professional who comes to you it's only
available in London Paris and Dubai
though and Dyson says it's going
cordless from now on at least with its
vacuum cleaners the company says it's
committed to putting engineering
investment into cordless vacuums as it
launched its latest model costing just
under 400 pounds we'll be finding out
what this minutes before then though
we're talking security because it has
been - the security encounter terrible -
see how the industry is keeping pace
with the changing tactics of terrorists
from military-grade weapons simulators
to high-definition x-ray scanners almost
every conceivable security gadget is on
show here in London at one of the
world's largest counterterrorism
exhibitions but the focus is shift in
winning the battle against terrorist
propaganda online has dominated
discussions at shows like this in recent
but after a year in which terrorists
increasingly turned to crude and
low-tech tactics to carry out attacks
attention is turning towards more
physical protection there are now
hundreds of different barriers on the
market all designed to stop hostile
vehicles and one of the country's top
counter terror phasis told me that
businesses should think seriously about
what they need over the last year at
husband will sophistication attacks
we've seen both and in London and other
cities all over Europe and what we're
trying to say to local authorities to
people who are looking to build in the
future why not / those protective
security measures and from the beginning
but protecting vulnerable sites goes
beyond just physical barriers the
antennas are driven by signal generator
this is a new type of body scanner which
its makers say could not only tell if
someone is carrying a weapon but exactly
what it is and they've already had
interest from schools in the US where
the issue of gun attacks is once again
high on the political agenda just pulses
and it listens these pulses of microwave
energy cause hidden objects - as it were
ring of a distinctive signature and then
the machine learning has been taught
over a period of seven years to
recognize the ring of these different
classes of weapon so it generates an
alert in real time and it can be
deployed covertly so you don't even know
it's there but some are warning that
striving for total protection of public
places can have unwanted side effects
the attack on Westminster Bridge has
ended up there with concrete blockers to
prevent a rerun of that but they're ugly
and they worry people you see them when
you think three I don't want to be so
secure that my life is a misery
traveling around London whatever your
views are on them it looks like we'll be
seeing more barriers scanners and
detectors in the future as this industry
adapts to an ever-changing terrorist
threat get Bradshaw Sky News so here's
why we're at one of the most famous
galleries from Modern Art this week a
team of art students and alumni have
been showcasing project design to make
us question how technology will impact
our lives in the future well now there's
a question to be greeted with by a mock
holographic cyborg on reaching the fifth
floor of the Tate Modern up here for
just a few days artists from the
University of the Arts London are
inviting people into question their
beliefs about technology's influence on
us and art Rex the robot reminds us how
artificial intelligence is increasingly
present and watching us live our lives
[Music]
I don't know Rex but you are very cute
[Music]
this is about challenging the audience
to re-examine their relationship with
technology and you know so we wanted
them to think about all aspects of their
lives like the love lives their health
care and surveillance the digital maker
collective is using the space here as
part of the Tate exchange program an
open experiment allowing organizations
to come in with new ideas it's all very
different to what goes on in the tape
models runs downstairs in the galleries
you can't touch you can't have a
conversation with that artwork whereas a
tael exchange we ask people to touch we
ask people to get involved and share
their ideas and their experiences on
this floor everybody's voice matters and
everybody's voice is heard
you don't even need a voice for this
project a headset that reads brainwaves
the more you focus the further the
needle moves across the screen I would
say this is a game not a piece of art
but this is it and I think that our
understanding of what art is is changing
and evolving you know what he's to say
that you know a game can't be a work of
art you know this is this is what we're
trying to do here for the project you
know really trying to push the
boundaries with you know what is
considered contemporary art you are
really concentrating what you're saying
right now it's exactly that kind of
discussion that the artists here wants
you to consider there is a lot of sort
of anti-technology especially within the
arts core you know you come to art
school you want to paint you know that's
why you've come to art school all you
want to you know make stuff for your
hands so so I think the the really
important thing with the dish to make
your collective is that you know we're
we're saying you can be making and it
can be exciting to use technology well
if this is what art school is going to
look like in the future and I predict an
enrollment boom
[Music]
staying with the virtual and interactive
now here's Simon with this week's video
games review riff star Raiders for the
PlayStation 4 is a 2.5 D top-down
twin-stick shoot him up and you don't
know what that is you basically take
control of a little craft and fly around
space and you shoot enemies key here is
there are a lot of enemies because much
like other games within the genre this
is really hard but that's the whole
point however the cool thing about RIF
star Raiders is you can play with a
friend when you are playing with a buddy
how does it make it easier because you
can team up but it's funny if you can
yell at each other
every time you die now if you never
played a game like this I would
definitely approach it with caution but
like I say the difficulty can spike
however is a lot of fun get your friend
involved gonna have a good time
scribble Nauts showdown for the Nintendo
switch PlayStation 4 and Xbox one is
gonna be one of the most original games
you play in 2018 and maybe just maybe
one of the best now the premise is a bit
confusing but it also is awesome
basically you get a bunch of minigames
all which are very accessible and fun
however before most of the minigames
you'll be given a top pick and you'll be
given a letter and then be told hey why
don't you come up with a food that
starts with the letter L then we come up
with linguini it will then give you
pasta then within that minigame you've
got to figure out how to use the pasta
to be successful it's incredibly
accessible it's fun for all the family
and if you like video games that try
something different you've got to try
this it's fantastic Scribblenauts
showdown
Ready Set party payday 2 for the
Nintendo switch which is also out for
the Xbox one and PlayStation 4 on paper
sounds like a really good video game you
and a bunch of friends join the big
group and you go and perform a load of
heists
such as robbing a bank so you get into
the bank you steal the money and you've
got to try and escape before the police
get their hands on you unfortunately
with a Nintendo switch version it's
really hard to play because technically
it's a bit of a mess the frame rates not
very smooth it doesn't look very good
meaning how much you want to enjoy it
but they'll be able to because again the
technical issues now if the developer
does fix this with a patch I will highly
recommend it until that day
stay away from this and keep an eye on
the internet to see if they can come up
with a fix Final Fantasy 15 Royal
Edition for the Xbox one PC and
PlayStation 4 is the best iteration of
Final Fantasy 15 yet where you do indeed
get the base game and you get every
single piece of downloadable content
that Square Enix has released to date
and if you're not aware of Final Fantasy
all you need to know is that it is a
Japanese role-playing game which means
you're gonna be doing a lot of talking
when you're not talking you're gonna be
trying killing huge massive monsters
that sounds up your street you know what
this will be on the street
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again for more
swype next week and in the meantime
follow us on Twitter for news you got it
right bye
[Applause]
you